bonjour louis marie sainte bonjour
maurice vient le temps bonjour je dit
rice ordinateur le matin première
oui vous êtes conseiller municipal ppm
et communautaire de la ville du cross
merci d'être avec nous dans sa au crédit
nous aurions dû le préciser louis marie
sainte conseil municipal d'opposition ou
désormais inféodé totalement
complètement à charles andré mancey le
maire de la commune
je suis conseiller municipal d'une liste
qui a été
élu au en 2014 ce qui est arrivé
deuxième il ya eu cette démarche avec
jean démence et l'année dernière
démarche très intéressante est en tout
cas très importantes pour la vie de
ducos ne sommes pas inféodés ou quoi que
ce soit nous sommes là vous travaillé
ensemble pour développer du cros et ça
c'est une excellente chose à mon avis on
va rappeler que charles vraiment c'était
le rdm de claude lise avant que contre
toute attente il décide de rallier ses
rejets team irs vue de cette élection à
la septième en décembre et ce grâce à
vous on vous a vu bras dessus bras
dessous se faisant des mamours à tout va
on va leur dire que le tchèque où se
poursuit
mais il n'y a pas de raison aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya une difficulté quelconque
de tourner le dos comme ce soit non
quand on prend quand on aura politiques
comprennent la solvabilité on y va
jusqu'au bout de cas pas le problème
aujourd'hui pour travailler avec son
environnement c ontre la bombe ont bien
et quand il ya des difficultés on se le
dit quand même quand tout va bien vous
avez parlé de la fête patronale je pense
que
ce dernier samedi soir c'était samedi
belle photo de famille n'est ce pas oui
mais je devais surtout ce que je retiens
c'est que c'était la première fois qu'on
faisait la fête patronale la nuit le
soir et c'était sale dans notre aussi de
notre projet je trouve que c'est une
excellente chose et que je pense qu'il
est
depuis alors depuis décembre
l'endettement c'est devenu conseiller
territorial et mais vous vous n'avez pas
bougé d'une place à la mairie du kosovo
est toujours à la même place à l'espace
sud ça vous va ça vous convient ben je
respecte la démocratie les jaunes
c'était si collégienne m'ont mis à 2014
est-ce que vous en vous la charles andré
mance et premier vice président de
l'espace sud il a il est signataire de
cette fameuse charte de dansant pour une
martinique nouvelle élue dû démissionner
de son mandat communautaire ce qui vous
aurait laissé la possibilité d'avoir une
place plus importante au sein de
l'espace sud certainement sans doute
mais vous savez que je ne suis pas dans
une posture de de
dd lui cherche obligatoirement un
mandala bay deal entre vous n'y a pas de
deal à ceux d'essence l'âge de
changement c'est un homme responsable je
suis aussi un angoissant sens s'il doit
le faire le fera mais c'est pas ça qui
va nuire une relation il ya eu un décès
celui d'emmanuel sylvestre en début
d'année serait plus haut permettre
également une redistribution des cartes
au sein du mit du conseil municipal ça
montre simplement ma loyauté elle
cherche pas de place et que ça n'empêche
pas encore de continuer de travailler
donc j'ai tout faux aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de prémices à ce que vous quittiez
le navire en vue de l'élection
municipale de 2020 l'élection municipale
2020 ses 24 ans est loin donc tous
beaucoup de choses peuvent se passer
peut avoir de l'isc on y trouvera une
seule liste attendons de voir
aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour
travailler dans cet esprit d'unité parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
problèmes sur ducos qu'il faut qu'on
soit soudées pour affronter les divines
notamment la hausse des actes oui là il
de ducos est dans une situation
financière très difficile comment ça se
passe la vie des ducs aussi comme dans
beaucoup de villes dans
un paysage politique français et
beaucoup de villes presque toutes les
villes de la martinique elle est
confrontée à des difficultés de
de recettes en tout cas des dotations de
l'état notamment et puis je crois
aujourd'hui aussi intense et des
investissements ça on le sait je l'avais
déjà dit auparavant n'êtes pas d'accord
avec son agrément c'est sur la méthode
il fallait mieux l'expliquer à la
population je crois qu'il faut mieux
expliquer tout à fait ce qui n'a pas su
faire ce n'est pas voulu faire non pas
du tout je pense que ça on n'a pas eu
trop le temps de le faire il faudra le
faire oui tout à fait parce que c'est
vrai que je les dis au conseil municipal
je reproche cette augmentation des
impôts même si je les voulais parce que
c'était une nécessité parce que je
préfère l'être soldat loyal loyal mais
surtout je vais faire ce sale c'est
parce qu'on risque d'avoir un budget qui
sera contrôlée par le préfet hélas le
préfère au hamilton qu'il voudrait donc
je pense que c'était une bonne chose de
le régler des choses de régler cette
problématique
je crois que chacun nous sommes soucieux
de ses difficultés financières
la population effectivement après un
conseil des impôts je pense que les
associations qui voient leur budget des
bbc il y également le hall des sports de
la commune vous savez à côté du collège
qui est fermé oui c'est fermé mais bon
je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que cette littérature situation qui
dure depuis une dizaine d'années on
aurait dû faire ce qu'il fallait mais
maintenant je ne vais pas
je les ai toujours dit quand je lis est
donc aujourd'hui je ne vais pas chanter
les alliés à monsieur le maire josette
solidaire je suis solidaire de la date
de ce qui doit donner ce qu'on doit se
serrer les coudes pour affronter la
réalité pour quand je moi je vais
rencontrer le maire pour
pour parler un petit peu de ces choses
là mais aujourd'hui s'agit pas de
remettre en cause quoi que ce soit il
faut affronter les difficultés ensemble
la carte politique du causse et vallon
de côté désormais via ce fameux tandem
chalandre immense et louis-marie 7,8 de
l'autre côté il y a marius narciso
aurait dîné là je sais pas c'est
tarifixe à clarifier la situation je ne
sais pas si en face une
une alliance entre les deux je ne sais
pas si ce jour les deux conseillers oui
à l'assemblée de martina à la ctm y en a
une qui est conseillère exécutive et
l'autre qui conseiller territorial de la
majorité mais justement et c'est ça qui
m'intéresserait parce que je suis du cos
nous avions nous avec ensemble martine
nouvelle nous parce que j'étais sur la
liste la même manière dans la manière
j'enlève mes moyens me ravaz et oui bon
ce qui est assez nouveau oui ne s'est
pas un problème vous savez c'est un peu
pour ça je respecte les yeux il n'y a
pas de problème ce qui est important
c'est le projet qu'avait pour la
martinique est bon dit que c'est gris en
au bout du cosplay il y avait notamment
le projet pour la zone d'activités
économiques sur près de 200 hectares qui
faisait sur carrière et fénélon du
concept a impacté mais la martinique
aussi est impacté ce premier pour le
projet il ya deuxième projet aussi qui
tient beaucoup au vert c'est une bassins
versants les deux problèmes du bassin
versant les autres qui parlent de
carrière j'ai déjà presque génipa qui
cause beaucoup de difficultés il ya le
troisième problème sous désagréable un
petit peu aussi la caf ou carré 1 donc
avec la voix avec aucun élu hausse est
de 6 mois terminés il va exploser non
mais et c'est là que je vais voir les
héris de ducos qui aujourd'hui a une qui
est à l'exécutif oui donc déplacé pour
pouvoir booster ses dossiers ce projet
puisque je n'ai pas trop vu de projet
chez eux mais de booster ses projets et
de faire un saut d'eau sous les ordres
aurélie n'est là la conseillère
exécutive de ducos non pas du tout est
alors retiré de nuit de mardi à mercredi
quand le maire comme conseiller
territorial mois ci contre à ses
dossiers pour faire en sorte que ça
avance et cela je vais voir parce qu'il
ya aussi la problématique qui touche du
conseil c'est à dire les voix il ya
certaines voix aussi qui à lille 2 ouvre
communal qui relie deux une autoroute ou
en tout cas il y avait cet accord avec
sir jeremy pour faire en sorte que ces
voies communales surface forme originale
on voit de la collectivité chimie a
perdu oui mais je veux dire que c'est la
martinique tout ça c'est pas un soir
d'automne cela martinez et se la joue
cool voix les élus puissent y en a deux
la majorité donne à l'exécutif a tenté
aussi ce projet visant à dénoncer pour
ducos laissons de côté purement du coup
c'est la municipale de 2020
laissons l'assemblée de martinique la
collectivité territoriale parlons des
législatives année prochaine dans votre
famille politique louis louis marie 7
arnaud rené corail est déjà allé pour
l'élection du statique dans le sud
expérience malheureuse nicaise morose de
cette lui ce n'est pas trop chaud pour
l'année prochaine est ce que c'est le
bon moment c'est le bon timing pour un
certain louis morissette
je ne sais pas
ordonné qu elle n'a pas fait un très
mauvais score je dirais que la fin très
bon score en 2012 puisqu'il est sorti
deuxième
contre toute attente et moi je suis ravi
de le dire parce que j'ai
j'ai apporté ma contribution à pendant
toute sa campagne législative où il
était un petit peu esseulé
donc ce n'est pas une aventure à l'abri
mais vous savez dans notre liste dans
notre liste il ya des hommes et des
femmes aussi bien sûr du cos que sur les
trois îles et que sur le marin que sur
st plus et qu'on vous regarderai la
liste des 16 415 la liste de ses
recettes est ce que vous avez envie d'y
aller pour la liste hâtive de l'année
prochaine je suis un homme politique et
je suis aussi un militant si on fait
appel à moi nous réfléchirons sur la
carte à la crème la somme à toi non
aussi on fait appel à moi je réfléchis
on fera appel à vos si vous faites
savoir que vous seriez intéressé par la
paix je suis un homme politique j'ai
déjà fait de bons résultats sur ducos
qui sont suffisants de 1000 voix ce
n'est pas suffisant pas du tout je
parlais pour parler de l'humanisme le
2020 je suis 2e bardy politique et aussi
qui est dans un assemblage en ville
martyre avec serge letchimy n'avons pas
discuté du tout mais je pense que ont
fléchi raus y en a 100 poules martin
nous verse faudra avoir les reins
solides face à geof l'ethnie lors oui
tout à fait vous avez ya aucune bataille
qui ne sera gagnée ou perdue d'avancé et
je crois que tout à chacun nous sommes
nous avons mis une expérience en 2015
dans un message je suis bien placé pour
le dire il est très important que nous
puissions avoir la meilleure candidature
pour les législatives de 2017 merci
d'avoir été avec tout ce matin louis
morissette on rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller municipal progressiste de la
ville à ducos également conseiller
communautaire à l'espace une bonne
journée merci d'avoir dans sa requête
inertie et bonjour